let's go to the phones at (617) 830-4750 and
see what's on people's minds.
Let's start with our color from the seven
eight six area code caller from seven eight
six uh, who, who are you?
Where are you calling from?
Is this me?
That is you.
All right.
My name is Christian.
I'm a student from Florida.
Hey Christian, what's going on?
Okay, so
I just wanted to ask you what, you could have
kind of had this idea recently that I think
the United States should move maybe more direct
democracy.
So I just want to see, what do you think would
be the best mechanism to achieve that?
Because I had, I just going to throw an idea
out there.
You can tell me what you think about it.
Yeah.
Imagine someone, for example, like Bernie
Sanders becomes president and he passes an
executive order that allows a law or maybe
a constitutional amendment to be achieved
by a direct national popular vote.
Yeah.
How, how do you think that's possible?
Do you think that's something that like someone
should strive for?
Listen, there are a number of different ways
that our democracy could become more direct.
One of them, as you're suggesting, is replacing
the electoral college with a national popular
vote.
That's a good idea.
The other thing you have to consider is that
when corporations and rich people have disproportionate
amounts of power and their desires are far
more likely to become law or policy than those
of someone in the middle class or the lower
middle class or whatever, that is a form of
making democracy more indirect by which it
is not an issue of the number of people that
want something, but more an issue of the economic
power that they hold.
So yes, I think there are a number of ways
that we can make our democracy more direct.
I've been talking about some of them for awhile.
Uh, and I think it's really great that you're
thinking about at Christian, but there's something
very strange happening on, on your phone that
sounds like crinkling papers.
So I'm going to let you go cause it's a little
bit painful to hear, but I appreciate the
call in a very, very important topic.